Oh
[Music]
jell-o jell-o jell-o jell-o jell-o I'm
gonna be honest boys I gonna be honest
boys our man is in the land and he's
ready to take everybody by the hand and
let them know that the plan is to stand
O'Dell they traded you O'Dell they moved
you to Cleveland and I believe 'land it
is about to get wild I'm telling you I
have a lot of vitriol for mystile
gentlemen I have a lot of excitement for
Odell for those of you not watching I am
holding the portrait because I need to
connect with the best wide receiver in
the NFL I'm gonna put this down I'm
gonna take a deep breath I'm gonna
process what is happening never in my
wildest dreams did I think that levy on
bail would come to New York and it would
be by far the second biggest news story
of the day here's the plan
Tuesday late afternoon I recorded a
podcast with the stick to football crew
you know them as Matt Miller
you know them as Connor Rogers great
conversation everything from how do you
handle this part of the year when people
are purposely lying to you what do they
think about the drafts where they think
about Haskins what do they think about
Cuyler Murray is he really not measuring
at his pro day Miller also secretly
broke news on Tuesday evening about D
Ford and as you listen you realize he
was kind of playing me
but that was before levy on that was
before Odell that was before a lot of
the move so I want to catch you up and
if you hear us repeat news and go
I wonder if levy ons going to go to the
Jets just bear with us it was my only
chance to get them in studio and I
really wanted to talk to those guys it
was great to have them I can't believe
they traded hotel ok some other news
that has happened first let me go
podcast with you homies great to see ya
33%
I appreciate y'all I really do from the
comment sections to the DMS
Twitter and Instagram you guys have
honestly been giving 34% and I
appreciate it and so thank you in terms
of switching the amendments boy are
people getting upset some people are
going absolutely let's make Patrick
mahomes the greatest quarterback we've
ever seen some people are going how dare
you how dare you move on from Aaron
Rodgers after one season of Patrick
mahomes and to you I say one season in
one game don't forget that Denver game
but I think it's a very fair battle I'm
gonna be going again to Atlanta on
Thursday night if you wanna watch me on
that NBA Twitter show but I'm gonna
officially put up another forum to get a
vote of Aaron Rodgers versus Patrick
mahomes it's to evenly spit split I mean
people are saying have some respect for
yourself mahomes is definitely the
greatest quarterback we've seen you're
an anti yet I love it
that makes me happy when it comes to
football dad I got a few in here I got
Howie Long for sure says TJ hua go he's
raised some super studs he be great for
you reg ptoo says Michael Lombardo he
needs to talk more and he seems like a
good football dad I thought that was
pretty good as well someone even got in
my comments and said hey forget football
dads what about a football stepbrother
and we get Blake bortles not a bad idea
I do think we need to call bortles I do
think that's funny that one was Sean W
show in terms of our favorite coach
lotta y'all love Sean McVeigh I got a
lot of Frank rights I got a lot of
Freddie kitchens I think I'm gonna
narrow that down to four or five and put
that on the forum as well and maybe I'll
announce that no correction I'm going to
announce it next Tuesday when I may be
welcome on my new football excuse me my
new sports uncle Charles Barkley
35-minute Charles Barkley podcast coming
on Tuesday it was awesome
get excited other NFL news that we
weren't able to talk about because it
happened overnight and also Wednesday
now that it's officially
the free agency year has started Chiefs
cut Eric Berry a little bit surprising
kind of shows you where he is with that
that injury to his leg
they of course went and got tire in
Matthew I had kind of hoped Tyrann
Mathieu Eric Barry I know they were in
the Earl Thomas sweepstakes
I thought kind of having both of them
would be cool but they move on from Eric
Berry and as I'm recording this there
are rumors that Eric Berry could be
going to Cleveland Ravens made two big
moves after losing four key cogs of
their defense they pick up Mark Ingram
the running back he's gonna be the load
back he's gonna get a majority the
carries but again they love Gus Edwards
that will be your two-headed monster
Mark Ingram Mark Ingram coming up to
Baltimore love that guy gonna be a good
fit the other guy though for Baltimore
Earl Thomas a lot of people say I see
saying you know Earl Thomas got a lot of
money a lot more than Eric Weddle got
Earl Thomas is a lot faster than Eric
Weddle
he's younger than a requital he's more
explosive than Eric Weddle there is
obviously concern him coming off of an
injury but Earl Thomas was one of the
coveted special players in this free
agency crop and I think that having him
back there with their three quarterbacks
with a good safety like they have a
really solid five or six in their
secondary that I look at the Ravens and
I go they gotta play the Steelers you
know they got to play this Browns attack
now with Baker Mayfield and Odell and
Jarvis and in joke ooh they have a good
secondary to compete I like to move the
Ravens interesting for you know the
first offseason for their new GM Eric to
Costa Raiders pickup Tyrell Williams
another good option there with Antonio
Brown to give Derek Carr a pretty nice
wide receiving court IRA Williams has
size he was always good for it over the
top shot and I'm excited to see kind of
what happens I'm getting breaking news
right now four years forty four million
twenty-two guaranteed so it's a it's a
two-year contract for 11 a year very
fair value for a big guy that has speed
that I hope Derek Carr could take
advantage of
d fort traded from the Chiefs to the
Niners you'll heal Matt Miller break it
down a little bit he was a guy that
opens them up to really take Nick Bosa
in the draft they got all those big guys
in the middle Arik Armstead Buckner and
now they get a true pass rushing threat
in d4 gave him a lot of money I know
some people were concerned about D Ford
because you know there's not a
consistent amount of production but
there was a reason he went in the first
round there's a reason he had a ton of
sacks last year there was a reason why
they franchised him and the Chiefs did
and let just in Houston go but D Ford
goes to the 49ers and gives him a pass
rusher that they've really been looking
for since do Merville I mean since Aldon
Smith and all that crap happened they've
kind of been missing that guy around the
edge I'm not gonna count no marsh and
all that but gives him and then you know
Nick pokes it goes on the other side and
I mean now you got a fearsome foursome I
don't know do you draft Josh Allen the
linebacker by I think it opens him up
and he deserves the money and the Niners
had money to spend bears I thought this
one was cool get cordarrelle Patterson I
love when Swiss Army knife weapons go to
good offensive coordinators Patriots
know how to use them
it looks like the Bears are gonna have
to move on from Jordan Howard I don't
think cordarrelle Patterson is your
traditional running back but he could
get three four carries and they can use
them in very creative ways
Le'Veon Bell goes to the Jets you'll
hear when we talked with Connor and Matt
we all predicted it was gonna happen we
all thought it would I put on Sims and
left go Le'Veon Bell secures the bag and
a lot of people on Twitter got mad at me
because he didn't get a lot of money or
as much money as we thought he was going
to get there was this notion that levy
on bail turned down 15 million dollars a
year in expectation of getting 1718
there's the famous TMZ clip where he's
walking down the street and he says I'm
gonna get a hundred mil there was the
quote where he said would you go to the
Jets for 60 million said he'll now he's
getting 61 in terms of all the possible
Mack
so it was a little underwhelming it was
not a great year for him to sit
James Connor really took down his value
everything that happened with Kareem
hunt and then being replaced by Damian
Williams and him having so much success
it only further emboldened NFL
franchises to go I know you had 90
catches but we can still get this
running game going with someone a lot
less expensive I'm gonna specifically
call out my man meatloaf who said this
show was just becoming a player friendly
podcast and not really looking at brass
tacks and saying he made a mistake
I said secure the bag meatloaf because
when you sign a deal for thirty-plus
million I mean bro that's still a
[ __ ] bag like that's our bag so I'm
happy that Le'Veon Bell got money he
took a risk he did not get the super
money that he needed but I could also
make the argument I don't know if he'd
want to be in Pittsburgh right now kind
of seems like a place where I don't know
go to New York be the face of New York
now that Odell is gone go to a team
that's gonna use you all the time not
saying that I think Pittsburgh is a
better franchise overall than the Jets
but with all the turmoil going on look
man the dudes a [ __ ] running back and
they don't get [ __ ] paid ah I don't
know what to tell you I'm happy for levy
on bill he responded to one of my DMS
all right I became a little bit of a
sucker that's myself scout I know it
didn't work out but you know sometimes
you got to get away a read you got to
get rid of that ex to find new pastures
and see what's really going on but I
don't think it was a shock it sounded
kind of like the Jets were negotiating
against themselves and that's how he got
here Odell
let me talk about why this is amazing
Frodo the Giants have proven that
they're an organization that has no
rudder the Giants seem like an
organization in the words of the man
Evan Silva maybe they're just listening
to Francesa and the fan base the fact
that Olivier Vernon Landon Collins and
Odell Beckham jr. were all outlasted by
Eli Manning is preposterous say Quan
Barclay is the Will Smith Fresh Prince
meme walking into the house and nobody
is there let me tell you the positives
for Odell Beckham Eli Manning can't
throw the ball over 40 yards Baker
Mayfield is going to be a top 5
quarterback for the next 10 years Jarvis
Landry Odell Beckham Nick Chubb Kareem
hunt David and Joe COO solid offensive
line Baker Mayfield and an offensive
coach in Freddie kitchens yet coming for
ya he has his wide receivers coach I
talked to someone close to Odell it's
his wide receivers coach from LSU who
worked with Jarvis and Odell at LSU he
was also on the New York Giants staff
when he first got there Odell is going
to a situation that is custom made for
comfort he's not on an island anymore
with some GM talking out of both sides
of his mouth and an owner that's always
ready to speak down to him he's got his
best friend he's got his former coach
he's got a quarterback that can make it
go and can we also talk about the
perfect balance between Odell Beckham
and Jarvis Landry even if they weren't
best friends even if they didn't go to
LSU together is there a more perfect
pairing of wide receivers route runners
and compliments than Odell Beckham
and Jarvis Landry Jarvis Landry is quick
and a phone booth has the most reliable
hands in the NFL and can work the middle
of the field
Odell Beckham can stretch a defense take
a ball 80 and is a constant threat they
were made for each other and for any fan
out there that thinks that Odell is just
a diva and he's gonna get upset he has
the support system around him to never
get complacent ever and he secured the
bag and Landry secured the bag they're
both paid neither of them have to worry
about getting paid competition what's
gonna happen they love each other I
didn't even mention Antonio Callaway
speedy is the Cleveland Browns and this
situation for our Adel are incredible
the Browns have the largest registered
fan base in the country Odell's gonna be
the number one selling jersey for darn
near the entire year the Steelers are
imploding the Ravens defense was slowly
falling apart and I'm not sure yet if
Lamar is gonna throw themselves into the
playoffs and the bengals well you know
the punchline there if he was still in
New York
he'd have another year of Eli where he's
the bad guy he'd have a year of a rookie
quarterback where he'd be the bad guy
and his entire prime would be wasted if
the Browns win big Odell will be as big
as LeBron Baker will be bigger than
LeBron Odell will be as big and I mean
that if you know Cleveland its Cleveland
Browns football this is a team that
hasn't been called a winner
for ever if this man goes there and they
take the strides they're gonna be on
national TV damn near 8 to 10 times the
Cleveland Browns are America's Team
and I want to put this down and I want
to look in the camera really quick old
takes exposed I'm not afraid
the Cleveland Browns will be a Super
Bowl contender for the next decade
put it on wax write it on ink put it on
my body I don't care I'm not getting a
tattoo that was a little bit too serious
and as you can tell I have a sweat on my
brow it was a little too much the
Cleveland Browns are coming look at
every other team that could be stopping
them in years to come
the Steelers declining the Chargers
Philip Rivers is getting up there in age
Chiefs boy that battle is gonna be sweet
but I like the Browns defense
have you seen their defensive line it's
freaking incredible Myles Garrett
Olivier Vernon and they just signed
Sheldon frickin Richardson the Jets up
and coming nowhere near what the Browns
are doing Andrew Luck and the Colts love
them not a big fan of Andrew Luck's
ability to throw the ball downfield for
years to come that's gonna be a concern
Texans good not where the Browns are
Jaguars Got Talent Nick Foles doesn't
have that many years left not as long as
Baker freakin Mayfield the bills let's
see if Josh Allen can throw a slant
there's only one team because it's
always that one team that could ruin
this and it's the Patriots but you know
that if I said to you Tom Brady and Bill
Belichick will be there for six more
years you'd look at me and say I'm crazy
there is no team in the NFL more
prepared and poised to dominate the next
decade than the Cleveland Browns old
takes exposed come at me bro I don't
care I'm all-in
Freddie kitchens my twin coach of the
year Baker Mayfield might win MVP and
Odell Beckham could be on the back of a
parade float getting toasted while Dave
gentlemen looks
in dismay let me pull take my attention
to Dave gentlemen as I calm down because
Dave gentlemen I salute you as an Eagles
fan I appreciate it I couldn't have done
better if I went in there myself and I
talked to a lot of people some people in
the Giants organization some people that
are Giants fans let me say this because
I did have some people reach out to me
and say hey Adam I'm a Steelers fan and
you went really hard on the Steelers and
it kind of hurt my feelings during a
tough time let me speak to the Giants
fans out there because I'm not trying to
be a hater on fans I'm a hater on people
I'm a hater on personnel I'm a hater on
front office and owners Giants fans I'm
legitimately sorry I am I can't imagine
what it's like to lose the young icon on
your defense and the young icon on your
offense I'm thrilled you still got sake
won I'm happy you got two first-round
picks to hopefully find a guy but man
I'm sorry I was talking to Giants fan in
the office today and they were it was
like a death that was like a funeral and
I'm gonna say this for one week I am
opening the bandwagon to be an Eagles
fan
I know but Adam I want to be a Browns
fan if you want to jump on that popular
bandwagon like I think they're gonna win
it all but I'm still being a fan of my
team you know that every time you watch
Odell you're gonna think about him being
in that red white and blue so go with
what caused you to get here green
gentlemen didn't want to dish it out the
Eagles are willing to come down i-95
boys come down fly spread those wings
and get used to beaten the Giants twice
a year if I was a Giants fan I would
take up the offer because I'm sure as
hell not supporting a team run by Dave
Kettleman but Adam he needed to make the
moves to fix
all those big contracts at Jerry Reese
they couldn't pay Olivier and Landon
Collins and you know what because they
had to go through this transition with
Eli it made sense to get rid of Odell to
free up cap to give them insane amount
of cat room with a rookie quarterback
and to all that I say I agree but I
don't celebrate a toddler for cleaning
up a mess that he made this was get
almonds fault I'm sure as hell not
giving him credit for trying to fix it
and to give up all those studs and to
get one first-round pick okay I just
look at Gettleman two years ago bro you
could have moved on from Eli one year
ago you didn't need to give Odell the
contract if you weren't sure causing
yourself to have 21 million dollars in
dead money excuse me 16 you paid him 21
and a half million last year for 12
games you made the mistake and if the
Giants are cleaning house and we look
around and it's completely bare send out
the maid two gentlemen you cleaned up
your own mess
pack your bags take a walk through the
door
Ernie Accorsi thanks so much man for
making that recommendation of an old
friend
that did the same damn thing in Carolina
got rid of Josh Norman alienated Greg
Olsen made all the offensive players
including DeAngelo Williams
uncomfortable to go up to the front
office thank God we got your friend to
be the GM of the Giants just another
example of the NFL caring about each
other and not caring about winning you
see Bill Belichick yesterday had his
shirt off diving in a pool laying out
there getting a back tan you know why
because when you get a target on it it
might as well look good
Bill Belichick ain't doing this stuff
John Dorsey ain't doing that stuff the
Eagles ain't doing that stuff the Colts
and Frank Wright and Chris Bowser
doing this stuff it's the organizations
that are run by these archaic GM's that
believe whatever they do is always right
couldn't be further from the truth
gentlemen a cleaned house take your
supplies and join them I felt really
good that felt really good
my only thing I'm gonna say about the
Browns there's two people that could
mess it up and their last name is Haslam
when you read that South Wickersham
article on ESPN and you saw how they sat
in every meeting and and as it got
bigger they wanted to be more involved
and they alienated people and for years
it was supposed to be a four-year
rebuild and two years in he fired Shashi
brown and completely changed course and
had rich Trey farmer and all that sit
down be the owner don't ruin this you
have one of the youngest teams in
football and the core is beautiful
please Haslam family I beg you I beg you
let the Browns be great
let the Browns be great the only one
that can ruin this is you that's it now
we got our boys Matt Miller Connor
Rodgers stick to football always fun
make sure you go and subscribe to their
podcast as always if you can watch us on
YouTube like share subscribe that's
great same thing with podcast and if you
ever see a clip that you really like
message me hit me up personally add Adam
Lefko I ain't too proud I got to fly all
the freakin time now and that's when I
answer DMS I love you guys
I appreciate your 33% I'm giving you my
33% and here's Matt Miller and Connor
Rogers each give it 16 point day and
five
I have two buddies in the studio and it
feels so good stick to football we have
Matt Miller we have Connor Rodgers even
though I've pointed at the wrong one how
are you guys good that new music is good
shout out rods it's really good cuz that
rod was like what kind of music do you
want I was like um I'm more of a funky
George parla like George Clinton and I
made it and I was like put it in my face
what's up Oh a lot of [ __ ] yeah holy
crap
so Miller you're in town because we're
having like an NFL summit bleep airports
trying to figure out what we're gonna do
to kind of change our coverage the NFL
and like get it like new and fresh we do
it every year
and I was like you got to come in studio
and I heard you guys are here yeah it's
gonna be fun it's been I'm brain dead
because we've been in meetings all day
we were well this morning yes and like
the whole time you've seen me in
Congress see me I'm like constantly like
looking at my phone like right I'm not
Adam Schefter but like I get a lot of
texts and stuff usually after the fact
it'll be like you know an executive
being like look who we just signed like
they want to brag about it instead of
send me that text three minutes ago and
man oh let me feed my kids NFL for
agency's been crazy you're here you are
a Jets fan you are and by the way we
work I'm recording this Tuesday
afternoon and so Anthony bar the gel or
the big the Jets had a big free agent
day yeah I'm like wow CJ Mosely and
Anthony bar yeah and then Anthony bar
went and turned around for less money
and went to the Vikings take away your
analyst hat as a fan were you upset not
really okay because at the end of the
day like he's a really good player but
it wasn't like like CJ mostly was the
grand prize you know what I mean like if
he walked away would it's not like when
they missed out on Kirk Cousins he was
upset about that one were you really
yeah I think so I get it well I think it
was more you know less about being upset
about what are they gonna do now cuz
they're picking sixth yeah right they
did ranted they figured it all out
thanks you're right if you guys would
have kept bar but lost Mosley it would
have been like oh no no we kind of
wanted bar because of most 100%
everything that mostly does would have
given bar the freedom yes run around and
make plays the biggest question now and
it's I mean
this now things could changes do they
allocate that money the right way
do they come away with levy on bail
maybe a Center in Matt Paradis then I'll
walk away be like oh [ __ ] theny bar
when this podcast comes out Thursday
morning as Le'Veon Bell on the Jets I
think so I say yeah I think so too
I'm seeing a lot of stories where his
camp is kind of floating out the
Baltimore Ravens just to kind of put out
the notion that another team is
interested yeah but all the other
stories are it's a done deal not a
strong market no and we had said that
for about a month and a half now we were
like who are the Jets bidding against
cuz everyone would owe the Colts the
Colts were never in on this they're
Marlin Mackin and once you realize that
like the Bucs weren't gonna get in and
the Raiders weren't gonna pay him after
they paid trip Brandon LaMarcus Joyner
you really sat around and like okay well
where's the market because he wants a
lot of money there only so many teams
that could pay that once you eliminate
need and money yes like okay he's gonna
be in New York jet but that's the thing
with love you know so like what is it
like to be the team that's gonna get
levy on bail like what's it like to root
for that team I mean it's a little scary
because levy on such a wild card yeah
now but on the flip side let's just keep
the glass half full here it's the most
perfect acquisition for Samms Arnold hmm
I mean I don't wanna and Jameson Crowder
is like that's what do you want for Sam
Darnell total everything ten yards in
under now you have guys they'll get
checked down all of the changes you know
they have the deep threat Robbie and
yeah so you're like okay this might not
have the Julio Jones this group but it's
pretty complete group where you feel a
lot more comfortable about what I like
about it too is a lot of times your GM
has made the splashy signings yeah and
these are splashy but it doesn't feel
over the top over the top and keep in
mind they're building a core these guys
are 26 they're all hands during their
prime the Jets aren't going one year
window they're going three to four year
window which is a much better feeling
and I think Connors tired to hear me say
this the salary cap is fake it's not
real I don't care how much CJ Mosley
signed for because next year he's gonna
be the eighth highest-paid linebacker
instead of the first think it's
constantly changing yeah look at Jimmy
Garoppolo everyone freaked out Jimmy
Garoppolo is now the 22nd highest-paid
quarterback in the NFL it's pretty well
also if you look at the salary cap it
goes up like ten million dollars every
year right I saw someone tweet this out
and I came in
so I apologize they should say the
percentage of the salary cap at the new
contract for a team I not the number
right like they're giving land in
columns 12% you like 12% that's crazy
other numbers are make-believe and also
the numbers that are coming out during
the tampering window are real likes good
like to max you know okay well CJ Mosley
will get 84 million dollars if he makes
every Pro Bowl for the rest of his life
14 million dogs you're the coax helper I
get like nine or ten with a lot of
incentives so it's like it's silly see
somewhere every agent right now and like
I know Lana kollek's agent well we're
buddies yeah he wants to be the agent of
the highest paid safe of course like you
want that because guess where he can go
now he trapped LSU Alabama grant Delpit
guess what I'm the guy that got the
safety deal no so it says six years on
the deal like I love the years of des
they always get cut in half I believe I
believe that and the NFL Network and
ESPN would never do this but it's
underneath it should say the guaranteed
money should be prorated to like like
Landon was like six for 84 which really
should be like three 456 like that's
what it should say you have to read the
contract it's translated right how many
years have guaranteed money the rule
normally is if you get guaranteed money
after year two it's a good contract
Landon guy right i think Moseley is
getting that like yeah everything else
is options yeah once you get into those
years three usually for a just it
steamed off that was Ryan Tannehill sign
for a hundred million dollars
everybody's like oh my god Ryan
Tannehill and he's already cut like he's
already gone I want to make sure that
whether you have like your slack or if
any breaking news happens we'll cover it
like I just saw Roger Saffold signing
with the Titans yeah that was one of my
I have a list of guys that we haven't
heard from yet but Roger Hsiao holds one
of those guys solid interior offensive
line play is hard to find the Titans for
the last few years have had their
tackles figured out their guards have
been an issue and if you're gonna run it
with all those guys including your
quarterback you need him so I like the
sign another good addition I mean they
went out and they got Adam Humphries
which is the perfect Marcus Mariota
target now they go get a guard and I
thought the Humphries contract is really
well done Sappho's I think none of the
turns about on the field that's about as
medical yeah seems interested they had
medical concerns but film wise it's it's
a home run if that's what you get and I
think he had a lot of offers out there
so picking Tennessee like you said you
want to you want to open holes for Derek
Henry had to need a left guard so it
makes the Titans you know as they uh
yeah you don't get too excited
okay the the other names that have not
signed that I think were we were
expecting more news from Darryl Williams
the top tackle hadn't heard anything
obvious or buzz no buzz I always wonder
if you're if you're a player do you want
an agent that manufactures buzz or is it
okay to lay low
it depends cuz like look what the
Packers did everybody thought they were
asleep the first day and then you wake
up and it's like holy [ __ ] guys yeah
nobody nobody really had you know the
mostly kind of details of it I'd say R
Crowder definitely not Crowder
yes it depends on the team I think like
levian is the perfect example of an
agent manufacturing buzz yeah yeah I
mean I I absolutely agree with that and
like does it all matter I always worry
about that you know cuz I definitely get
used you know with what we would love to
go because we were just out of draft
season the combine is like the ultimate
[ __ ] meter all the time because it's
its League deals and draft evaluations
the next few weeks people are totally
gonna be manipulating you guys like
you're gonna be getting messaged by
agents or teams trying to throw off
other teams like how do you deal with
that you have to know your relationships
you know just like I've known the both
of you for years we've we've broken
bread together we've had a lot of drinks
together I trust you if you told me
something I trust you we're friends if
some guy just walked in from the office
it was like oh hey Miller by the way I
don't know that guy so you have to I
think you have to vet where your
information comes from but I've also
been used by my friends is what I'm
gonna say I've had guys god I wish I
could tell that story
there was a very blatantly last year
someone told me two days before the
draft our coaches are like making a late
push for this guy like you put it out
there okay I did it wasn't true they
were trying to make sure that no one
like they were generating interest for
another player
but wanted the media and they wanted
other teams to think that they really
liked this one guy so do you text them
the next day and go yeah what the [ __ ]
okay yeah you do and it's like sorry but
I owe you one and then do they pay you
back
always Wow and did you feel okay with
that because there's party that's like
hey I appreciate you snow yeah you feel
a little dirty and it's it's hard and I
would bet that if you had Adam Schefter
on here if you had Ian Rapoport on here
I don't know if they would be as
transparent about it but it happens to
anyone who works in the distributing of
information for the NFL because it is a
trade off like it you scratch my back I
scratch yours and then you know but
every now and then you just get get used
a little bit what's the biggest piece of
information was there ever a story that
you knew but you weren't confident to
put it out and you're like damn if I
would have broken that that would have
been pretty awesome
oh I'm Conor probably remembers more
than I do because that I'm I'm like why
didn't I do this ya know yeah okay I got
one I love that you thought about like
this is my this is my relationship with
news I think that it is an insufferable
insufferable position to be a news
breaker from Adam Schefter to Jay Glazer
they always talk about how awful it is
for their lives I was at breakfast with
quit and Nelson and quit Nelson's like
you know this parts off the record said
quit I don't have a record laughs no I
don't want to be that guy it just I
don't want to mortgage my friendships so
I have to can i yeah story time let's
play first one was that when the Niners
called the Patriots about quarterbacks
they called for Tom Brady I knew that I
know what happened I grew up a Niners
fan I have a lot of people can go back
and look if folks are listening to your
podcast on it with them and I knew that
that they called for Brady but I was
specifically told like we will kill you
if you put out there that we called for
Tom Brady the Patriots were pressured
that why would they even tell you
because it's like you'll never believe
what we tried to do right and then the
other one is that I was actually I was a
story this past summer and it was a
out the it was pitched as the fall of
the Patriots when will it happen so I go
I travel all over the country and I'm in
this conversation and turns out the
story ended up being why the Patriots
are gonna win another Super Bowl and but
one thing I heard was someone I was
walking down the street with him and
they went so the Raiders are gonna trade
khalil Mac and this was in late May and
I'm like what and he's like yeah it's
gonna happen like there been a lot of
conversations that as soon as they can
they're gonna trade khalil Mac and
they're gonna start over he's probably
not the only one they're gonna trade but
I was I was sworn to you know like hey
you can use it for context but dude I
don't want to hear it on your podcast
and you can't report it Wow and so
that's usually when i text Conner and I
text my brother and I'm like so we can
start steering things in this direction
but I can't report it you can start like
changing the way you do your mock drafts
or you can start like discussing like
hey maybe the Raiders are gonna like
look at this value defensive and the
third round right or what would a
hypothetical khalil Mac trade look like
I think we actually did that on the
Stiletto
podcast and it's like so yeah you hear
things and you know yeah just have to
see on the opposite of I heard something
about Bryce Harper go to the Phillies
and I said man whatever I don't care man
that's so funny the other names I think
that we haven't heard anything about
haven't heard a wink about Golden Tate
know enough haven't heard anything about
Justin Houston and has not Coleman Tevin
Coleman Mark Ingram marking room maybe
the Ravens in Dhamma can sue I don't
know what's gonna happen especially
because they gave that money say he
wants to stay on the west coast but I
don't know where on the west coast who
has money yeah
KJ Wright is one of those names I
thought I'd hear a lot more and Earl
Thomas I haven't heard anything about
those guys yet either and again this is
Tuesday this will probably change yeah I
think will Earl Thomas he wants more
money than he was willing to pay at this
point I still love her al Thomas I know
that Dallas some people I think James
later and said Dallas must pay eight or
nine well Earl wants like 14 to 15 and
to be honest if Landon's getting that
money
I think he's worthy of more than know
they share an agent right oh man is that
malagueta Mulligan yeah yeah as does
Kenny Vaccaro well that's the thing he's
the same guy yeah okay so this agent
his name's David Molly got a mulligan
once in Texas also also represents
Derwin James also represents Jalen
Ramsey Shawn Watson he pretty much has
all the best secondary guys Paul Adams
better call yeah yeah I had a tweet
yesterday and I deleted it before I sent
it cuz I didn't want to piss off every
agent in the world but it was like if
you're a defensive back prospect that's
just go play for him he has all the
information he knows how all the deals
get done yeah it's pretty impressive it
is pretty impressive and then Ronald
Darby I think is like another corner
that has an Eagles fan on say he wasn't
that great yeah he's a top cornerback
guy in a bad corner market yeah I mean
Bryan Callahan is like the guy and he's
a slot corner he was great last year but
it's just a bad corner stand Coleman's
got a great great money that's the
general effect I think a lot of people
don't think about free agency this way
that the draft affects free agency
because you know if it's a great it's a
great edge class people aren't panicking
because that will draft Joshua Wright
will draft
Montes what it is a bad receiver draft
in my opinion in a bad corner draft so
in that matched up with bad receiver
market frayed seat even if the bills are
signing all of them right and a bad
corner well you know I mean all I hear
from you guys too is the defensive line
class and this draft is incredible and
I'm looking at you know the Darius
pylons and the sues the Timmy Jernigan
stand the Henry Anderson's I'm like
those guys are gonna have trouble
because there's so many teams but what's
so funny I think every year is when
there's a deep class everyone assumes
they're getting one yeah we're gonna get
one they never think if things go wrong
it's a deal
I got a plan until you get punched
method where it's like oh we were wrong
like nobody wants to be with the edge
class everyone's like it's a great edge
class right you've heard it a million
times in like so the Chiefs at 29
they'll just draft an edge well who the
[ __ ] you gonna translate cuz they could
all be gone by then do you know what
there's four really good edges maybe
five we'll say five they're gonna go in
the top 15 mm so it like supply burst
demand is still over and we've learned
this from honestly like just trial on
the Monday shows for six to football
we've been doing mock graph Monday not
every Monday but a decent amount of them
and we keep like learning the trends
we're like wait a minute if you want a
pass rusher outside like pick
6 16 18 or whatever like your toast
after that so you got to get into that
yeah
what are some other trends you guys have
realized oh man I think that like how
many quarterbacks do you have going in
the top ten consistently three right
yeah
Kyler Murray Dwayne Haskins Trulock yeah
and I think now it might be three in the
top 15
without trades yep one thing that we see
the corner is always fall yeah yeah yeah
- leaving Green William even greedy yeah
yeah which man if you actually just saw
a mellow tweet this if you want a fun
tape to watch go watch Kriegel em [ __ ]
NDK Mecca
really yeah phenom Laureus like if you
want to like follow a greedy williams to
be like maybe the jet should draft
greedy at 3:00 or something like watch
that watch him against the ik and I
guess I'll watch me get George's we're
gonna get to your team's in a second
because you're the second and third
picks in the draft the Niners and Jets
respect I'm not an Irishman anymore he
likes the Patriots and the Chiefs now
what if we make fun a non-stop wait why
well I cuz they're good on offense I'm
from Missouri so there's that right
that's my this so not my cousin Niners
do something to lose your family
I don't like John Lynch hmm I loved him
when he got hired they were applying for
the same job
yeah Chelsea they ran into each other it
was like John Lynch was coming out of
the interview and he was gone right John
he's like Oh Matt and it was just like
like retire it did you like Berta Jersey
we haven't done it yet we're still
pondering but I don't we do live where I
live and the quarterback and the can see
Chiefs is patrick mahomes it's really
hard to not you so I put for the I put
this towards the homies about the
amendments our first two amendments were
Aaron Rodgers the greatest quarterback
that we've ever seen in college Shannon
is our favorite coach in the NFL and I
said they're both up like I am I would
like to make Patrick mahomes and I've
gotten a lot of people yelling at me on
Twitter oh I got your back but Kyle
Shannon is no longer my favorite coach
he's never come on in person the podcast
right now Sean McVeigh is leading Doug
Peterson's up there and really you know
it's probably built on a dark horse
Frank Reich yeah he's pretty crude I
love Frank right yeah it's pretty great
but it's really which coach is gonna do
me the most favors that's yeah yeah I
like how you work
yeah I mean you should get you the
dinner table we saw and just have it
bring them rolling together at the
combine yeah all right so do we have any
good combine stories that you're allowed
to tell because right Thompson had the
article and we've all heard the story
side service good article but I don't
think it was it was so surfaced love
imagine if you had never been to a rock
and roll concert before ever right and
maybe just like kind of enjoyed music
and then you would to a Metallica
concert and you were like these [ __ ]
rednecks jumping around they're all
drunk they're all hopped up on pills
what is this [ __ ] show
that's right Thompson covering the combo
and what is it actually that but it's
also there's like man I'm there for a
week and I will get a year's worth of
information in that week really yeah
it's the most valuable spot because what
every scout is there every coach is
there every agents there 336 of the top
players in the country are there Matt
the NFLPA guys are on there like that is
the spot man for what I do for a living
that's so you have a week so that's 24
hours times seven you take out sleep how
do you how do ya how do you use that
time like do you go okay I'm gonna talk
to a bunch of scouts today like do you
get right to the point like how do you
head oh you can't it's like dating you
know unless you have a relationship
already then you can just slide it in
you know but otherwise it is like you
know you go to the bar like I'm you post
up a high velocity in the JW Marriott
yet where everybody stays right and yeah
that's how you know I'm gonna buy a beer
and be like oh hey what's up Matt
bleacher report oh hey you know Connor
the Jets and then you know hey if you
guys had a good draft last year yeah you
know it's just you just feel each other
out and they're not you you know hey let
me buy you a beer and then you know it
just goes like that I mean it's and then
you create a contact and I just never
understood why a team official would
want to give you guys in for me it's
like we're talking about Clio Mack you
want someone to talk to like yeah
especially if you're an area scout like
if you're an area scout for a team that
doesn't value your opinion which is a
lot of them yeah you want to talk to
someone finally so let's say Connors and
area scout for the Jets and they're not
they're not like this but say and he's
just tired of Mike in the cognitive
Noren him he's like I told you we
shouldn't have drafted Darren Lee in the
first
right he wants to tell someone yeah hmm
why not tell me that's austin's we're
friends we've had beers together yeah we
got a lot in common where do you guys
stack up in the coolness meter compared
to other people that are there do you
think you're cooler I can answer that
yeah I don't I'm taller I've got a lot
of the people really the NFL media is
pretty sure yeah generally shorter yeah
you would be like a giant yes you'd be
the big you would be the biggest person
yes because I I make a lot of jokes
about when I here area Scout says Kyler
Murray's instincts are below par and I
go is this a Regional Scout is this like
yeah like we hope the word scout and we
act like it's the head of the scouting
department and we blow this little
tidbits it doesn't really mean it yeah I
think that's something that my editors
forced me to do a really good job of is
not getting away with that like they're
like okay well why would he know like
and they'll challenge you to be like and
sometimes we I'll get upset me that guys
I can't put a bigger label on this that
you want me to assign so sometimes we
just have to cut information of like I
can't tell you that
it was the director of college scouting
for the Minnesota Vikings because
there's like one of those I could google
that there's 12 area scallops right it
could be anybody so it protects the
label and I agree with you though left
go where you do wonder like what is the
value of it I actually this is something
I really love that I know you and Daniel
Jeremiah both do this in columns polling
because polling at the end of the day
whether you value the scouts opinion or
not gives you a general consensus on a
topic I think polling is the best way to
do it like something I did for the first
time ever this year at the combine I
pulled the scouts I knew and asked them
hey who are your favorite interviews
like what guys did you enjoy sitting
down was short at the end of the day I
knew who the for like AlphaDog smart
leaders were of this draft class it's
like cool just good to know yeah cuz
there was a consensus I got the same
answers almost everything everyone's
like slobbering over Quintin Williams it
was Quintin Williams Devon white Cleland
Ferrell and I'm trying to think who the
last one was I don't know why I'm
ferrell the one for Clemson that has all
the personality who's the defensive line
Chris Wragge
yeah he's another guy that old that old
Chris Wilkins is in my mind like when I
look at the left go PR he's the guy that
ever team he goes to is good
like a young face of the franchise he's
funny he's engaging he's innocent he
does the split that's which is the
funniest that the split is like he looks
guys at 315 pounds and he does a false
he does like a dance and then a split
how do you feel about him we're 42
though I love it you like that I mean
it's for a college like that's not yeah
oh yeah he's definitely I do college
like you got pass rushers we're in
seventh I've heard were you with me when
I heard this conversation I was talking
to a bunch of scouts I think it was an
Indian I thought you were there and they
were like I will never draft a guy a
deal I maneuver single-digit and yeah
those are the guys were either like
right right on their name and I never
give them I know that like it just
doesn't look good yeah like I know that
like you're soft
who is the kids right a month was it
from Princeton that war 11 the past
Quran read yeah and he were like 11 I
was like you know what that is
that's a fat guy that knows that 11 is a
slimming number really and as a guy
myself I dig it yeah but like you can't
wear eight out there you know like
alright let me do a few more NFL teams
and then I want to dive into the draft
with you guys two teams that have a
young quarterback that are going all-in
right now and trying to spend money I
believe are the bills and the Jets Josh
Allen and Sam Darnell respectively the
bills not a lot of sexy names with their
free agents but a lot of names that
collectively you go this is a Sean
McDermott team and it makes so much
sense they get Cole Beasley and John
Brown you mix them with Foster and with
Zay Jones and now you have some speed
some underneath guys not sure if Josh is
able to hit the underneath guys but
he'll try I hit him in the face man
right now yeah Frank Gore gives you a
leader Kevin Johnson I am not a big fan
of I think it's kind of panned out that
we're not sure but Mitch Morse and taina
Seki the center and the offensive tackle
for Washington this was a Bills
offensive line last year that was a mess
and they just signed oh well now the
Panthers signed Matt Paradis sign Mitch
Morrison right can't look at Twitter and
do this now there's so many news things
coming in but re-signing Jordan Phillips
yeah I I just like what the Bills have
done and none of them are big contracts
out really none of them in horses and
it's to get a franchise center it's hard
to do it is and he has been hurt I mean
I don't see me the big issue for him but
I think you look at the bills that you
said it's a of an inexpensive defense
and a quarterback on his rookie deal
which obviously we all know makes you be
more aggressive but I like that they're
getting tough players
yes that's like okay you want somebody
go over the middle I'll go over the
middle left go PR Cole Beasley you need
a music video oh he does and you need to
do a rap on the plane about Buffalo
buffalo is a team that I've learned at a
fan base and you guys know this too
they're a little bit like the Saints if
you say something bad about the City of
Buffalo or the Buffalo Bills they will
destroy you they're very protective the
best thing you could do is go I ride for
Buffalo and if Cole Beasley wrote a rap
song about Buffalo I am willing to take
be our staff go up to Buffalo we will
shoot a music video can you imagine him
in the snow
he's like be on double LS ma FIA like
something that would be because the
tables in the background yes yeah and
then he drops and then he gets slammed
through a table we'll go in together
we'll do a tailgate tour their deal and
I'll die that would be I don't know how
you guys do tailgate tourists cuz I
would just be direct it's usually you
gotta go in like with the plan like
usually we get their setup I mean it
varied we got there anytime from 5:00 in
the morning to 7:00 in the morning yeah
and then you sit there you guess it'll
be a little something to eat and you're
like let's do the show now because they
get out of hand
the and also the guests if we had a
guest they prefer to come over early
okay I'll let you we had Jake a pastor
who's a legend there we knocked him out
in the first hour and then we're gonna
get for beer pong yeah like let's just
have fun and you get to meet everybody
hey that was the coolest thing about
doing Sims aleph coat the Super Bowl is
just getting to meet everybody I say hi
one of the other the Jets getting
Jameson Crowder getting CJ Mosley
obviously no Anthony bar I also think
Josh Bellamy is a super underrated
signing yeah ah special teams
Josh Bellamy has been the special teams
guy for the Bears for the last few years
and every time I turn on the game
he's the one making the tackle without a
doubt and you look at Bram Boyer there
they made it a priority to bring him
back right like they fired Todd Bowles
and his staff and Boyer was the guy I
think the Jets finished as the top
special teams unit last year and Boyer
actually has a voice there because of
how well his unit performs and that Adam
GaSe you know brought him back
it didn't look to hire externally right
and it goes to show you when a team goes
out of fridge didn't give him crazy
money but you have a legitimate NFL
contract in two years six million
because he's viewed as a special teams
ace yes
so that it's important and I think it's
something that the Jets have had some
really bad special teams year yeah and
they finally have learned to value that
unit I will say this is my my hot tank
please about the Jets they can't close
they cannot close the deal and we we saw
it we've seen it with I mean we talked
about Kirk Cousins Tony Jefferson Fanny
bar Anthony bar trades for Khalil Mack
like Mike mechag ninh cannot close and
so I think like that where we're sitting
here like since Tuesday afternoon levy
on bail still out there if they don't
close levy on bail I like and I know it
doesn't matter that Matt Miller is gonna
roast them oh just a third person I hate
that but I will be all in on like
scorched earth that like Mike McCadden
has to go because you have all this
money the second most money in the NFL
you haven't drafted well you got a
rookie quarterback who's really really
promising and you got a cash it you got
to do it you got to do it now and if
they for whatever reason whether it's
Chris Johnson doesn't want to spend
which CJ Mosely just got 84 million they
want to see yeah they want to split
would mean what would be the reasoning
that you can't i Anthony bar doesn't
want to leave I can understand like a
hometown right kind of thing but man if
you can't close the deal now it's gonna
be bad the other team that I love the
identity they're going with is the
Packers oh my god yeah stealing Adrian a
MOS from an individual rival and really
not paying him anywhere close to a
Landon Collins or a honey badger getting
Preston Smith on the edge and za'darius
Smith the issue with the Packers that
I've had for the last year is sure you
have Kenny Clark sure you have Muhammad
Wilkerson you got yeah and you got clay
Daniels yeah he had three guys one of
them gets hurt you're ruined for the
whole year to get Preston Smith and
za'darius Smith they're not going to be
double digits at guys
you know what they are they're gonna
bang with that bears offensive line
they're gonna bang with that lions
offensive line and they're not gonna
they're gonna give those linebackers a
little bit of space to not have to take
all those guys and then Billy Turner
yeah I said sound like that offensive
line has been so hurt right and you see
Bob any bodies yes I felt like that was
a smart signing if you want no you're
not gonna like change your pants over it
like that's a pretty good signing just
for building a football team yeah what's
shocking to me is that last year they
gave Aaron Rodgers this record-breaking
contract and now they're being
aggressive in four agency still like
that's great to see if you're a mattress
and you like finally finally Ted
Thompson's gone and we're actually being
aggressive now two off seasons in a row
right last year was Wilkerson a Jimmy
Graham like you're finally going after
players and trying to put something
around Aaron Rodgers yeah I I get
excited too
I think it's a pretty good amount of
money for za'darius Smith to be getting
like 17 a year for the first two years
that might be a little bit much but
they've loved him for years they tried
to trade for him before I found it
interesting to watching him because this
year I made it a point to take a break
from college from him just watch the
free agent pass rushers I knew this
would be a group that Jets would be
interested in and I would cover and
za'darius a lot of his wins all came
from the interior actually staanz twist
so I actually liked that yeah they got
to edge pass rushers but they got two
guys they're a little different I think
Preston can win by turning around the
corner and with more converting speed to
power and I think Siderius someone from
the interior so and stealing a MOS
that's a whole nother I just love what
they did I love what they did we were
talking we were kind of laughing about
this like when the Packers wake up on
free agency do they get everyone in the
town hall and like everyone votes on
like who they say hey bus yeah yeah
there's like 500 people and they walk on
out baskets doing like a church
collection we took too long I love that
no but I think it's it's nice to see a
Packers defense starting to be built
I thought Penton did a really nice job
with what he had but it was always a
gimmick to try and make up for the fact
that they didn't have depth alright
let's talk some some draft and I went
talk about how free agency impacts the
draft and kind of where you guys are
right now first thing is
Kyler's Pro Day is tomorrow
what kind of a scene are we expecting
and obviously this is gonna be happening
yesterday when the pod comes out I mean
there's over a hundred media members
credentialed I've never heard of that
many media members my first combine
there were that many media members so
it's gonna be a circus there's been
speculation about you know the report
came out he's gonna get measured he's
gonna run he's gonna throw I heard today
from somebody in the NFL he's like I bet
he doesn't like I bet he doesn't get mad
I bet he doesn't wait yes yes everybody
lose no doesn't have to do any of that
it doesn't have to do [ __ ] I didn't I
thought Scouts can go there and this is
all an assumption you'd know more than
me and and ask he could literally say
get a ski he could say no yeah I mean
it's just like they could ask hey we
want you know we want you to do this why
not measure him again like if there's a
relation of measurements are gonna be
rough it's an indie you would think but
there's like legit speculation that the
indie wasn't real they want him to be
measured again we and wait again
explain to me that conspiracy theory oh
the conspiracy theory is that he's not
actually 510 or 1/8 that people who've
measured him at Oklahoma people have
seen him at Oklahoma because Scouts like
Connor said they've been through there
they they have measured him or they've
seen him there's a straight the training
staff is obviously measured a guy at the
University of Oklahoma that he was you
know five nine and five eight so explain
to me how that could be lying about
there is like a pseudoscience out there
where they will massage guys backs to
make them to stretch you out to make try
to make you a little bit taller so that
I think the belief is they they do it in
the morning right in your there there
yeah so you I almost made one too we
just move on yeah it's $59 you know it
can apparently make you a little bit
tall remember that who was that that
quarterback prospect last year they got
a chance well Jared Goff was one of the
big ones again he got his hands massaged
but then why does he just get the
massages before the pro day I don't know
if like you would have the ability to
like if you know okay at this time I'm
getting mad oh you're saying that he was
like in the hallway getting might no I'm
telling you what I heard like that and
what did you believe I don't think it
matters who cares if he's five nine a
5/8 or 510 or 1/8 like are we really
ever happen in a scalable
where is your where do you guys boast in
Kyler's qb1 III have Haskins ahead of
him I'm fascinated by calamari very very
close like I think both deserve to go in
the first round I will admit that I
think one of my you could call it like
it's weird cuz I think it's a strength
of my my ability as an evaluator and
it's also weaknesses that I into all
field stuff a lot and I think that
sometimes that can work if you get in
the right situation sometimes it can say
if you get in the right situation how
good is off the field I mean yeah I I'm
not gonna go Charlie Katz really here
but I don't think it's exceptional yeah
he's not gonna walk into a room and win
you over like Baker Mayfield or Sam
Donald so I'm gonna say this that was
the knock against Lamar Lamar was super
quiet yeah didn't really do a lot of
leadership but what I kept seeing in the
off season and in training camp and then
in the season was Lamar's actions won
the team over I think that's important
like a lead in many different ways in
training camp
I remember they always like the middle
of the season they were asking about Joe
Flacco and he said he said this isn't
about being my team or his team this is
our team and it wasn't eloquent and it
wasn't super well-spoken genuine but he
said it and the whole team was like
he'll be honest for a minute the only
reason that that stuff came out of about
Lamar Jackson is because he does not
speak like the rest of us right he
doesn't sound like I do he doesn't sound
like you do he has a different it gets
back to the racial implications of
saying that somebody's Welsh exactly
that's that's 100% was so like Omar
Jackson didn't do well what about Tyler
what's what when like what why are we
saying about I think he just comes
across as aloof you know and like maybe
not super engaged and my counterpoint to
that is if Kliff Kingsbury has already
told him hey we're drafting you at
number one
don't go play baseball then it doesn't
matter ya know no matter he was probably
aloof in the meetings because he's like
bro the number one gray team is already
interested and I also know like I mean
these interviews are 15 minutes it's so
hard and they buzzers right like there's
not like hey stay for one more meeting
you got to get the [ __ ] out of here and
get to your next one next door and
here's the thing it's easy to live for
15 minutes but it can also be really
hard to for me to walk in here not
knowing you guys yes I walk in and
you're like okay Miller so
what happened on this play like or why'd
you quit Texas A&M and I'm like okay
well there's five minutes you know you
just yelling at me yeah and now I only
have ten minutes left to convince you
that I'm a leader and then I'm
respectable and that my teammates gonna
love me and that I'm gonna handle money
and I'm not gonna quit on you and it's
like Emily how are you gonna do this in
15 minutes I also factor this head
remember when Deion Sanders apparently
went to like another team and said
you're traveling at eight you're not
gonna be asked him about that we had him
on the podcast yeah and then he was like
he was like you're not gonna be around
to pick me so I'm not gonna waste my
time the Wonderlic because I'm gonna be
on the board when you and and you know
what that's when Charlie casually goes
on TV and goes you know one team said
that Deion Sanders is a complete [ __ ]
and that nobody should draft him it I
want you to do the accent oh no he's got
like that like this Mane where is he
from
so you're you're Kyle it but you said
first round I thought Kyler was like Lok
at top ten oh yeah I said both you mean
the first round both should be top 10
picks Haskins and both of them together
I look at Kyler and I go someone that's
that special someone that makes that
many incredible plays there's you can
see the ball jump off his hand
you see the accuracy you see the
mobility if it's able to be if he's able
to be injury free it's a slam-dunk and
here's the thing that I love the most
he's elite at protecting himself please
small it's a small target his strike
zone non-existent great awareness right
like I like Tamar Jackson more than a
lot of people but I would admit the
awareness there to protect himself from
hits was almost non-existent at time
house with Kyler it's like whether he
slides goes out of bounds or just the
stop and go like I just worry about
health with him he's never been hurt
right I mean he was he was the best high
school player in the country he was fine
what's the Texas A&M played didn't get
hurt went to oh you play didn't get hurt
I don't worry about that like I mean
yeah he's probably gonna take a toll on
him and he's gonna have to stay on top
of it but yeah I think he he's an elite
athlete there's something about those
former baseball players where their
spatial awareness is so good like
they're used to like see in the field
and all that or like waiting like that
second look at Patrick mahomes who did
not a great athlete if you put him on
the track and say Pat run a 40 right but
you watch his spatial awareness his
short area quickness his instincts his
flexibility is balanced like though you
watch all that Pat do all those things
you're like oh my god this guy's an
amazing athlete
yeah and it's because of that you know
quad sport background right and then
Haskins what's very funny about the
discussion about african-american
quarterbacks the NFL Draft is we
typically go through the same thing
every year
it started off with Stephen a Smith
saying he was mobile the best thing is
that it ended that conversation right
away because it was such a public gasps
overhead it was he's the least mobile of
all the quarterbacks the second thing
that I heard was people comparing him to
Byron Leftwich and I said the thing is
you can be big and you can be strong but
Byron Leftwich was defined by an
elongated motion so when you compare
someone a Byron Leftwich you're
comparing you're saying he has a long
motion i watch Haskins and you tell me
if I'm crazy that ball gets out of there
quick like he is it's surgical it snaps
he's so accurate like even even watching
throws at the combine I'm going those
things are laser but yeah yeah I mean I
love this guy Matt stone I've loved this
guy since the summer before he won the
starting job you know one key game in
2017 against Michigan where I believe he
led them on the game-winning drive but
he's always had the talent that's the
thing he's always had to town he finally
got his chance and he has everything you
look for in a pocket passer but I like
to see him have a little more ability to
improvise and extend plays of course but
in terms of pure throwing there's
nothing you can ask of him that he can't
do and then I think about the Giants
offense and I think about if he gets the
ball out quick
to those guys right what that offense
could be I get really excited if he were
to be there I've heard they do love him
so there's a good chance comes there I
compared him to Carson Palmer I'm like I
mean a pocket passer who like you said
it can be surgical times I think the
ball comes out quick and I think like it
was so exciting about Dewayne Haskins is
first year starter so you go back and
watch like week 1 and Oregon State I
think gosh kind of a slow start but you
watched the last three games the year he
played Michigan northwestern and
Washington
those are three of the best defenses
that I watched all year and not in those
games
I tore them apart so I think with him
it's important to know the trajectory of
where he ended up at and that he is and
something that a lot of people don't
ever want to say about african-american
corvex he is incredibly smart why can't
we just say that like he's so he's yes
so so good he's up there with Jared Goff
as far as you know just football IQ of I
know this stuff is easy to me you know
yeah for some of us like you learn
things just it's easy for him football
it's just easy man and then how do you
see Locke as another top-10 guy I mean
he could be drafted in the top ten I
don't think either of us would tell you
that he you're a little bit lower on him
yeah I mean Connor now that Connor comes
up to me he goes Sims his favorite
quarterbacks gonna be a lot I told Sims
that the last time I saw him because I
didn't know he was leaving [ __ ] in
any and he said hey have you you know
Who am I gonna like who should i watch
they just watched Trulock you're gonna
love him you're 11 he's a big strong
armed athletic an accurate quarterback
but he hated Josh Allen's I don't get
that like right Oh Sims love Josh I
can't remove all over the place love
Josh he love Josh challenge Sims really
liked the quarterbacks last year but
when I was watching lock I was like okay
he's got the gigantic arm right loves
that he throws his mechanics are bad but
he can throw off platform get there from
any Sims loves that yeah of course and
he honestly moves well for a big guy
really does so I was like oh like Sims
will live with the mental errors that
are mind-blowing a time all right so can
i I'm gonna ask you guys some questions
that I've learned watching the last few
drafts between those three guys Kyler
Haskins Andrew Locke who had the most
talent around him
I think Haskins well no no I would go
Kyrie Murray has four of five offensive
lineman will be drafted Wow
some of them highly and then how many
weapons Oh I mean Marquis Brown if not
hurt would be a first the first receiver
off the board CD lamb who's an
underclassmen will be next year I mean
they they just have weapons yes CDs like
excellent what about every task is
because of his running backs were so
good JK diamonds Mike Webber you've got
two great receivers with scary Terry
clarin and you've got perfect sample so
speed it or what about a line there okay
like Michael Jordan and Isaiah Prince
will both be drafted then
be drafted very early but they were a
little bit young so uh Michael Jordan
yeah and then what about drew luck no I
mean not much yeah watch all will be
drafted so I asked this because every
year sometimes we see quarterbacks that
are surrounded by talent get drafted
then we go man that's why Mettenberger
win
that's why why Johnny Manziel went
because of those and then we miss on
guys like dak who not a single a player
on that offense for mississippi state
was even draftable and i see the dirt so
hear about one of my all-time regrets
right there what I loved dak I had like
a early two on him and then the DUI
happened right after the pro day and
then everybody talked about that right
week but then it got dropped and I'm
just an idiot and I never but I had him
in like the third so the reason I asked
that is just for awareness when I hear
you guys gush about who played with
Kyler and who played with Dwayne and
there you go nobody on Mizzou I go see
that's a bump up there for drew Locke
just like it was a stop down the SEC
with exactly yeah but lock played
against the SEC well kind of I mean
Mizzou is not playing Alabama yeah but
how do you factor that in with a guy
like Kyle are Duane with all those
weapons that kind of made you have to
like watch every game yeah and you have
to look and see okay did Marquis Brown
make Cuyler Murray or did I remember
liking Dan Lefevre you remember him the
central measurements you know Dan look
he was a quarterback of all total Brown
yeah I think JJ what was his title right
so you're like oh well yeah it wasn't de
Lefevre it was Antonio Brown so like
that is our party to check that out what
do you look for to figure out who makes
who I think you look for like with Kyler
Murray I want to see him throw
accurately on time over the middle of
the field yes so who was there right
getting there but if he throws to the
back hip instead of the front hip does
Marquis Brown still catch it and because
he's so damn fast right he's able to
scoot and shift and make somebody miss
and like oh my god that was a 80 yard
play but it should have been incomplete
like that's where you can't look at
numbers you can't look at analytic
grades like you have to actually just
watch guys play and especially for
quarterbacks like you have to look at
where was this ball supposed to go where
did it go was it was it a 40-yard bomb
but should it have been
80-yard touchdown ready under through us
oh yeah there was yeah I remember the
first quarterback that I read was right
on was Jake Locker
because I remember Washington played
Syracuse that year and Jake Locker threw
for like three four hundred yards and I
went all of those were wide receiver
screens that guys took 70 yards but
around the draft they're going this guy
had 17 400 yard gains I was like he's
not good guys yeah now playing gabbert
was another one of those like
everything's why everything spying
scrimmage dude like can you throw
downfield and under pressure like some
guys are barely pressured in college and
I think it's something that's gonna be
interesting to watch with to it next
year because tool plays behind such a
good offensive line and I think Georgia
got to him a little bit in the SEC
Championship we're like whoa through 200
interceptions all year in this game he
looks completely normal and I says it's
someone that loves to and I believe into
it but it's something that evaluators
will do you have factored that injury
yeah and like there's so there's so many
layers our jobs really easy though if
you're gonna go out sir is your point
about lock something that makes me feel
more comfortable about and I do think he
has a lot of talent I'm just not sold at
all he was a senior this year so we got
to see him a lot more than Kyler and
Haskins where it's like yeah he's a
three-year well I wanted to see some
steps this year and I just didn't see
them it was his most accurate year he
went over 60% fine totally but it's a
lot ya know who at 2 should you're so
why my old 49ers would you how much of
your salary what percentage of your
salary would you bet that collar Murray
goes 1 oh man I mean I feel pretty good
about it I would say I don't know and if
a trade happens you get all your money
back like if they if they trade out of
the pic oh right now then I'm getting
that I'm giving my salary yeah I would
go like 80 percent of my salary they
were either taking him returning the pic
I can't fish I do agree that taking Nick
Bose is the right way to go I don't see
them doing that I just know that since
Kliff Kingsbury interviewed since he was
at USC an interview with the Jets and
Cardinals the only thing I've heard from
everyone in the NFL is that he loves
Kyler Murray it's just this thing he
talks about all the time
and here's it's a weird thing to just
bring up
like when you're hired as a head coach
or even when you're hired as general
manager you don't always have carte
blanche to do whatever you want
ownership has to sign off and every move
that you make so we can all hear hey
cliff wants Cuyler but Steve chyme the
general manager is saying no I drafted
Josh Rosen last track traded up for Josh
Rosen right work with him or Michael
Bidwell the owner could say nah we
traded up last year to draft a
quarterback that you told me you
believed in the plan was this yes go
with that so it doesn't always matter
what Kliff Kingsbury well but there's
two issues right one being that if cliff
does want calamari and the Cardinals
don't give them to him and this year
goes poorly that's a one year disaster
that will just blow up
well everyone fired I think everyone
there's a chance everyone could be on
the flip side Josh Rosen takes things
personal and I could see him taking this
entire offseason extremely personal and
not in a good way I think it's too late
for that
this time so the combine when they say
josh is our quarterback for right now
right now they just keep saying for now
right now yeah I don't know it's just
but you're willing to put 80 percent of
your salary yeah Tyler Murray is going
100 that coffee and you said we have the
insurance policy that if they trade it
yes yeah then I'll go 85 90 oh I don't
think you should who do you have as the
number one player on both of your boards
Nick OSA
yeah and is there a gap between boast
and the next guy yeah not really for me
I really like Quinn and Williams number
two so he would be number two and like
the do you guys have the same I have a
Oliver at number two right and then
Quinn in three and then you have who do
you have it through Josh Allen Josh out
of three oh you have Josh a lot lower
yeah he's gonna sit between 12 and 15 so
it sounds like the consistency though is
Nick Bosa and Quinn and Williams are
both in your top three yeah they're
stars I think that's where where is
Kyler in your top I haven't met 11 or 12
yeah where do you have me look right now
for you but like where you have a player
ranked is not where they'll be drafted I
mean you know it's like what your rating
is for Bosa like what do you have oh so
great it is OSA I had her all probe yes
the way my grading system works I
actually put a number great on players
so that I can go back and look at past
years and say this is comfortable so I
have Nick Bosa
graded as an 8.0 which is really
really good miles Garrett was an 8.5 so
I liked miles Garrett a little bit
better
last year Bradley chub was a 7.95 so I
liked so where did you ever did you have
cloudy so clowny was before at bleacher
report we started doing the number right
that's right
but he would have basically been like a
perfect like a 9.0 9.0 is perfect yes a
Kwanza 9.0 von Miller right clowny
Andrew Luck only 9.0 yeah I've Kyler at
nine and I could see you nine in your
big I could see him gentlemen a few
spots because Jeffrey Simmons got hurt I
never really docked him for that right
yeah actually though you know it's one
of those weird things where you do you
kinda I do always do that late because I
asked this to Connor before would you
rather have Josh Rosen and Nick possa or
Kyler Murray and a defensive lineman
that that comes up in the second round
you can reach over slap make this answer
I don't know because I haven't been in
the room with Josh Rosen for a year mmm
you're right they should have an idea if
he is being a problem that people are
now saying that he kind of has been I
know Larry Fitzgerald is gonna come out
say this isn't true but they're enough
people are saying like I kind of rubbed
people the wrong way and that's funny
because I talked to Pugh and Pugh was
like we love him really that's great
yeah because he was like he was like he
came in right away and I think Pugh is
also a guy that's like I was with Eli I
was in New York the media's and saying
yeah he's like there's just not a lot of
stories going on and our players can
like a player and coach is not as well
but you're absolutely right you know
like like I mean like we all love each
other but like Dave finocchio might not
like one of ya you know and it's like so
it's different so let's say Kyler does
go number one Arizona and I really am
NOT interested in the trades where do
you think Josh Rosen would go by the way
if you had to get Washington Washington
or Miami now Miami missed out on Teddy
Bridgewater
yes scrambling so Miami make sense okay
he would get killed down there though
you know what all Jews eventually I mean
it's gonna happen eventually right we do
that's what we go down there we go to a
deli it's phenomenal huh Niners at - it
has to be Nick Bosa even the Quinn and
Williams is like auric arms that like
all those guys it's just simple cable
Quinn Williams there I really am but it
has to be Nick Bose and here's something
else that I was
to try to connect the dots long-term the
Niners came in his fridge and see what a
lot of money and they came out on day
one and gave Quan Alexander thirteen
million dollars a wild deal but besides
the fact they have a gigantic need at
edge pass rusher and they had the money
to solve it all those guys in the market
good players upgrades and they clearly
did not have interested in doing that it
would make some things look tough year
for edge though just because in the free
agent so many people got tagged sure but
like they didn't even try to add a
Preston Smith my point is it makes me
feel like they know something well I
think they know that they know Nick Bose
will be there it's or Josh Allen so
Europe your cup exactly they have an
insurance policy where they're go we're
gonna get our guy I mean if they left
this offseason with like Justin Huston
and Nick Bosa I would be if I was with
the Niners defense like not to go super
in the weeds nerd oh please do but over
here they signed quite Alexander to play
I would assume to play either Mike or
will but that Fred Warner who's a
third-round pick rocket last year I mean
in that 4-3 under like if you're gonna
put Buckner at three technique I guess
an Armstead it knows sama Thomas you
really need one guy who could play with
this hand in the dirt and you really
need one guy who could stand up and play
Sam linebacker that's what they're
lacking right now so like Josh Allen's
me makes sense as a Sam linebacker he
stood up some in Kentucky like oddly
enough Anthony bar would have been like
a really good Sam Josh Allen off the
ball yeah I really do it something that
nobody talks about I feel like but they
could also sign Quinn and Williams you
want interior pressure I can't stress
that enough it's interior pressure is
more valuable than exterior I agree yeah
look at Aaron down look what Khalil Mack
did the flush for Cox
yeah everybody nothing but look at aaron
donald and dom consume so you would put
80 to 90 percent that Kyler Murray goes
one if Calipari does go one what
percentage of your salary would you go
to Nick post it goes to I would find a
way to bet 150 percent I was exactly I
would look at any assets I have I would
go home to my parents attic and find any
valuables I had located my ex-wife so I
would like oh man he wants to go into
this
like how can I go into this right now
okay he's engaged now this is a
conversation we should probably have hey
hey get your fork or okay what so so if
we got pretty solid Kyler's going one
yeah we're doing the draft for you guys
you don't even got a watch Yeah right
well the way this is we would love for
you to watch to tell them because you
said we have not announced yet I'm very
happy I'm gonna be joining these fine
gentlemen for our draft coverage this
year it's gonna be awesome yeah we're
gonna go live we're gonna have all of
our videos cut out gonna be in the app
as always but no we're going nonstop and
when TV goes to commercial we're here
and we're gonna have insight I've heard
Twitter and YouTube will be the places
to watch nice maybe more but at least
those and you can ask anybody when we do
the draft we're usually three picks
ahead yeah and if Millar gets news that
someone's gonna be drafted that we're
just gonna break in because if you want
to watch it and watch the theatrics on
TV the way I always recommend people
find out the pic before television does
so that you can listen to the breakdowns
and like yep get the news first then go
on television watch him get announced
great watch the hug with Goodell and
then back to us because we're gonna be a
head of television I I was we were
meeting Stan I was telling a story a lot
of my friends last year they were doing
like the three screen thing you know
like BRM one and iPhone that work on and
then ESPN and they were like well be our
three picks ahead and like they're
they're actually talking about the picks
yes not about Baker Mayfield while we're
on picked right like we will talk about
the player that is picked not storylines
from three hours ago
no not day three whoever is on the desk
with us we will be talking about the
players picked on day three not the
[ __ ] narratives from you guys are so
good on day three so we kind of the
first two picks done so then what about
your jets oh man
because what's interesting is you have
Josh Allen at nine or eleven I forget
what you just say yeah between 12 and 15
so 12 yeah 13
Josh Allen 13 but it sounds like a
player that's a guy that fits the most
out there are you like what a montes
sweat guy are you know quitting Williams
matched with sweat is not a 90s R&B
singer by the way
I am a and I've said hi I've said halls
I somebody right now and I can't we're
gonna take a pause really quick okay
what a phone call you know that was
Goodell how's he doing he said he said
listen I hear you were stick to football
he would not want to say hi to us we
should on him all the time yeah it's
easy it was nice that you got on the
phone because I had a nice break to just
read my mention some people furious with
me that the Jets didn't sign Matt
Paradis what do you miss with you I
don't know I just was like because
there's a lot of news around they're
like oh the Jets are interested in all
the center's and I was like well I
haven't really heard that there that
like interested in paradis and then Gary
Vee tweeted it takes two to tango
obviously Gary Vee is his agency yeah a
Jets fan right so I read that and then
this I I'm not saying I got my info from
Gary yeah of course I was saying like
for what he saw I don't know Jets fans
are very upset Sam Donald doesn't have a
center right now and I get it
I totally I know especially after this
some of the snaps in that Miami it's
just really bad that in six weeks
there's not this other player
acquisition period you know like today's
your only shot to get a Senate sit there
if you don't get my college guys just
that they don't know any good I would
say this is even funnier we're recording
this on Tuesday free agency has he
basically started yet yeah one of our
the players could go back to their old
teams instead of signing money on one of
our super stick to football listeners
has just been going off like once to
like drink himself into oblivion because
the Colts n well I get it so Jets at
three yeah oh the non Jets fan first
please do mean you did this a little bit
like yeah who do you think if it goes
Kyle if it goes Kyler and Nick Bosa who
would you take if I would take Quintin
Williams I think he's the better player
and I also Leonard Williams right
Leonard Williams this deal is almost
done right has it been great there so I
think you protect yourself against that
like you and I were just say an interior
pressure is the key so I know they don't
have a second round pick yes they need
an edge rusher but I would I would
rather pay someone in the secondary free
agent market and half Quinn and Williams
cross sport Quinn and Williams reminds
me of embiid where it's like he's the
best player of the draft and somehow
he's available at 3:00 and it's like
this guy
be that got like if in ten years we look
back and go wow Quinn and Williams was
the guy none of us will be surprised no
doubt like all of us I would just trade
that early 3 4 D Ford yeah that's
straight up yeah the Chiefs aren't
asking for much
third rounder Oh No the Chiefs the
Chiefs just want a third round or back
for D Ford I think that's a great I know
right that's why I should be running
especially because you have that much
money that you can afford the salary I
use it well now he said quit and
Williams who would you go at 3 now I
have to make the pick right cuz I'm
still convinced they're not gonna make
this pick you have you think they're
gonna do trade it right whoever wants to
come up for Dwayne Haskins can have them
where's your like order Locke would you
do that would you help the Giants though
would you fix oh I could care less it
wouldn't help you last year what about
the Dolph no they did well they did
unintentionally yes a qualm what about
the Dolphins no it depends on your
evaluation at all of the quarterbacks
because if you as a team feel that the
quarterbacks that they would have
available for them aren't any good you
go sure you but you have to double
charge this so if the double charge so
the guys though are like wow we really
think Dwayne Haskins to be great in a
way you're like I don't want to face it
yet you haven't done you don't know I'm
doing Haskins though yes I would see and
this is what but this is what we should
but yet they haven't you always should
the I know Matt what he knows so that
like sad to say yeah sketchy that's
really and he says they're not really
big sources tell but yeah Matt it's like
a rollercoaster like in terms of waking
up I saw what he's like I'm [ __ ]
exhausted and then like he slowly comes
back to life and then you get to like 8
o'clock at night and it's all the way up
top and then BAM I'm gonna be on that
like for old-fashioned high and then
smack ya know you you really can't trade
to a division rival ya know but they
gotta get out of this pic okay so here's
my devil's advocate pic now and I think
this is it's not sexy I don't think
people be like yeah cool like Vaughn
Taylor no but close the Jets don't have
a center right now
giraffe Jonah Williams play Med Center
and then when Kelvin Beecham's contract
runs out you move into left tackle mmm
so you get like two for one
yeah totally I still think job is really
good I really like Jonah lamps you just
have to trade back really far to
convince me that to do that then I don't
think you really like him though eyes if
you really like to me good sitting back
man we got this new 93 are you upset
that with all that with CJ Mosely
signing that you're definitely not
getting Devon white no CJ mostly fun
fact when I was in I think that was my
senior year colleges the first year I
ever like did the draft from my wherever
I lived in [ __ ] yeah you know I mean
and for a blog for free
CJ mostly was like the first player when
I did a board that I ever truly liked
loved Wow like I loved how do you feel
right now I couldn't be happier
I didn't even care you a Jersey buyer no
okay if you were so here's what I will
be I said when I make a home office I
will be a Jersey buyer because I'll hang
them up god that's what I do
yeah like I wanted my first one will be
Jamal Adams LSU because I love LSU like
I just from going there oh the Jets the
Predators made me a custom yeah you
gotta hang that up that's it yeah that's
really big Manchester United made me a
left go Jersey when I first started
bleach report and I gave it to my
brother
oh yeah cuz he likes soccer I just gave
him all my free [ __ ] yeah well I gave
mine a job so I understand yeah exactly
alright so I'm looking at this a who or
a player who is a player that you think
is gonna be over drafted on draft day
who's a player that you guys are already
going man he came back CAF mmm Rashad
Gary holy [ __ ] those are the two names
my gosh on Gary I'm seeing everybody's
top ten right now I have many top 10 I I
just I seriously so you guys are two
different on this oh yeah I love looking
out for you right now you go first I'm
at six I think you can't miss
immeasurables the combine were insane 30
is an athlete 30 and 39 39 we need to
come back like in a year yes
so okay so you have a yes right not soon
enough Gary at 39 versus six let me hear
the six argument well you it's all about
traits that you
can't I've said this so many times you
can't be like well watch Ohio State in
2017 and you see him do this and this
this you you just can't it's not there
but when you see someone who is his size
as fast as he is as strong as he is
unless he's just mentally soft and it
doesn't he seems to be pretty sharp to
me then like that works and so then how
do you justify it then not having
production yeah I think some of it could
be usage you know they asked him to play
inside a lot of Michigan when I think
he's actually best on the outside on the
inside teams were able to double him
chip him a lot which is why guys like
chase wanna [ __ ] on the edge was able
to have a ton of production because
everyone's focused on where Sean Gary so
I think it's it takes a little more
context but you can also it's like Josh
Allen last year if you like him you can
look at the contacts to say well but
look at these reasons why he wasn't
productive if you don't like him you can
say but he's got to be productive right
and now you're 39th argument okay but he
wasn't productive the film isn't really
good he was hurt and I get a lot of
Salomon Thomas fives a player that I
really did like and everybody loves
solvent learned the hard way what did
you learn from Salomon Thomas just that
these tweeners that are athletes that we
bet on don't always translate and then I
look at their athletic profiles and you
go okay Salomon Thomas four six nine
forty gary was a four or five eight
three cone which is most important thing
for defensive linemen Salman Thomas six
nine five four Shawn Gary seven to six
Wow seven six is bad man bad but not at
mean at 277 yes it's not it's not the
illuminating solvent Thomas way he
actually with 273 but Salomon Thomas's
three-cone was in like the 90th
percentile
I think he's developmental pass rusher
where he's so wrong Matt is spot-on he
has all the traits in the world but you
get to Michigan and you're the guy
higher rated than it Oliver
and you're you're this guy that is
fighting through injuries and the
instincts on film aren't really there
I'm like I can't take him in the top 15
I can't do it so what do you say when
you hear that I was saying about Solomon
Thomas because I understand and you're
still a Niners fan
just put in he was a redshirt sophomore
so he was he played one year at Stanford
and he went to the Niners and was
expected to be Warren Sapp that's what
John McDonald I got my Warren Sapp and I
got my Derrick Brooks with Rubin Foster
and he was expected to be something he's
not if he had been able to go somewhere
and play as a six technique defensive
end in a 4-3 we're probably talking
about a different trajectory for him but
instead he was the number three pick in
the draft and he just he should have
never really been drafted out highly I
don't think I think a lot of people
overvalued you know his character and
his leadership an absolute law like you
when we first started talking about I
think Aaron Donald came out the year
before so an under sized interior
defensive lineman was like very in vogue
at the time yeah yeah I mean that 2017
draft was kind of a weird one too you
know I mean like because you're talking
about like other best players are Jamal
Adams but you don't take a safety that
high and then but there's Rueben Foster
but he's crazy
there's Leonard fournette but he's hurt
and there's this incredible quarterback
but he went to Texas Tech yeah or just
Shawn Watson turned the ball over too
much of Clemson yeah it was a weird
draft year um DK Metcalf where do you
have him in your big board I have him in
the 20s I believe which is like a
concession by me I'm at 21 which is not
where I want him to be but you really
want him to be where like 45 no like 39
probably right there over Shawn Gary
O'Connor sport I've met 17 I think ace
he's so raw the thing with that is like
if it clicks or if he goes somewhere
were they okay like you're really good
at straight line if they use him he's
gonna be fantastic when is this guy ever
clicked and when I say this guy I mean
every year there's a wide receiver that
tears up the combine and we go but if
Prashad Perryman clicks but if Kevin
white clip if Corey Davis John Ross well
if Darius Hayward Bay clicks and when is
it ever clicked um Kenny Britt maybe for
a moment you know like I mean but it
doesn't like Evans had production Oh
Mike Evans was great he'd heard up she's
not he's not a comma yeah yeah I don't
know with Kim Butler I just watching him
play I've never seen on Hakeem Butler
I'm sorry but he has the same argument
well that's why we're doing yeah Hakeem
at least has some moments where you're
like oh man but yeah whoa DK I
my big joke is I want to see if he can
put a seatbelt on what like can he put a
seatbelt on
you know like bodybuilders they're so
stiff they can't oh he's back you know
what I guess if you're reaching down for
balls right
what is his ability to adjust to the
ball because at Ole Miss he really ran
one route and he had guys like a.j brown
so I asked us to cut its gear combo if
you had DK Metcalfe why not put him on
the outside and have him run 30 goes and
if he's got single coverage you lob it
up and if he doesn't you know they got
to be afraid of his speed right like can
you build an offense where you just go
he's faster and bigger than everybody
and guess what he's going deep that you
have to go to the right spot because if
you go small where they want nuance to
route running if he goes to New England
which he won't think it's not gonna work
yeah but if he goes to New England
they'll customize their offense all
right they would put him at tight end
yeah though say this would DK and I
think Matt agrees with me considering we
have him what four spots different yeah
I mean I haven't $79
more you know what I mean like where
it's like Oh in the red zone he's going
to win the jump ball or if you throw him
a screen he's going to pick up 25 yards
is he can cut he can stiff-arm he can
run through you you can run around you
so I do think and we're probably and so
maybe we're getting suckered in again
but I would bet on him like I would bet
on that range it's it's interesting to
reset cuz like it's like we're Shawn
Gary all over again yeah like something
your bets like at some point you don't
want to bet against rates that's why I
like with Baker last year or Cuyler this
year you'll hear people say like I'm not
gonna bet on that guy because he doesn't
fit the thresholds you you will bet on
the guy who's has the traits which it
should almost be the opposite because I
think you can look at just really good
football players are still really good
football player exactly there's so many
calculated bets when you take when you
do the draft analyst role like Devin
Busch is probably a more ret NFL ready
linebacker right now the Devon white but
Devon white is just so rare and has made
so much jumps over the last two years
we're like okay I like that might a
little better because I do see a higher
ceiling and
feels like he's gonna hit it so I'm
looking at the like some mocks and stuff
and I'm going DK Mecca if a lot of
people had him going like nine a buffalo
Buffalo just went out and picked up two
wide receivers and free agency
yeah and I'm kind of looking at the
other teams and I'm going you know DK
Metcalf going to Green Bay at 12 would
be a lot of fun you know what I think
will happen though
yeah oxen billet 7 Jacksonville at 7
just got Nick Foles they really don't
have receivers they think of all the
guys that left and free just so many
other holes they really do yeah but you
know defensively they kind of kept some
of their guys your offensive line like
fell off a cliff last year so I don't
see Detroit making a lot of sense
because they have their two guys there
Denver I know yeah they do need a wide
receiver
I like Courtland Sutton and I like but
you know like they're not sure what's
gonna happen with Emmanuel Sanders and
all that stuff but I look at Miami I
don't even know who the quarterback is I
look at Atlanta and I go no I don't
think so no Washington I just
you need a quarterback first yeah
exactly Carolina's interesting they are
interesting they need offensive line
help yeah though badly I think we've
ology and they need defensive end help
so we've always been like well that's a
there's a Jonah Williams spot where
that's a Cleveland fertile spot
Cleveland Cleveland would make some
sense I mean they've been trying to hit
the home run everybody and your brother
will tell you they've been trying to get
obj yeah like a month yeah so it would
make some sense to me and then if
somehow he falls to 22 Pittsburgh he's
their new martavis but they'll just take
a guy on day two and make him a star
you're right yeah JJ are single
Whiteside yes third round
so now I don't think there's any way he
falls this far but I'm thinking about
maybe teams trading up Seattle
interesting Baltimore they need a
receiver interesting Houston yeah you
just wanted to go the Eagles your well
no I'm thinking like if you know if he
was there for Oakland at 24 him and a B
is a pretty awesome combination can I
ask you an unscripted question on your
own podcast
there's no script here where are you at
on Derek Barnett now cuz remember you
had your famous like you walked off the
set like I can't believe we drafted the
fat pass rusher yes this team and then
like you'll want a Super Bowl in I feel
like he
had a above-average rookie season I
thought he was solid I thought he made a
bunch of plays like he was the one that
were covered the fumble to win the Super
Bowl last year he gets hurt the Eagles
are investing in Derek Barnett as their
next defensive end they go there they
get Malik Jackson with Fletcher Cox they
paper in and Graham Derek Barnett is the
other guy now he has to be the guy in in
basketball he's our Ben Simmons in
baseball he's our Reese Hoskins he is
the guy that has to hit to make this all
work I think that Derek Barnett to me is
a very solid pass rusher and I'm curious
to see how he comes back from the injury
with a whole year of working out rehab
and all that I didn't think he was that
quick around the edge I didn't think he
was that great against the run was
crafty though but he seems like a very
solid defensive end I just that was one
of my favorite moments ever wish I was
amazing that in Joe Cardona Joe Cardona
it's like five Super Bowl rings now it's
incredible great what a career but the
thing about Derek Barnett is he that
that was the reason I reacted that way
there are certain story lines around
draft time that we just talk too much
about like the Reggie White statistic
was just that doesn't mean it's gonna
translate like if that was the case the
kid from Louisiana Tech would be in
Ferguson he would be a top 15 pick I
mean he broke terrell suggs a sack
record but it it production doesn't
always translate so that was my issue
who do you guys your favorite player in
the draft yours was Ed Oliver and Devon
white are your two favorite players just
favorite when you talking about like my
top players but like you just have
favored your favor oh yeah yeah I think
you're even white as well I mean at Josh
Jacobs from Alabama I'm running back
Josh Jacob I got two actually and these
videos are gonna come out later do
interviews with a top draft prospect and
then a Hall of Famer so I got to be in
the room with Terrell Davis and Josh
Jacobs man and just talk for like 20
minutes yeah and I did this with Nick
boson Orlando pace I did this with your
dude from Louisiana Tech and I can't
remember the whole famers name right now
but I did it with Tim Brown and the
hunter Renfro from Clemson Fred Dean was
defense event that's great there were a
few moments that were super cool hunter
Renfro is in all of Tim Brown like
hunter renfro's like one of those guys
that knows history he's like you played
for 17 years like how did you last that
long
and he's like a little kid and he's been
at Clemson that long so he should yeah
yeah sure he's 34 years old
Cole thing was with Josh Jacobs and
Terrell Davis it ended and Josh Jacobs
was still asking questions Terrell Davis
and he's still and he's all ears and the
attention is there and the foot and I'm
going may not because I didn't know who
Josh Jacobs was you know I'm able to
handle interviews and be like you know
you had a big old career there in
Alabama but I'm sitting there and was
like I started for one year dude and Wow
and while he's talking I'm surveying up
and down and I'm looking at his legs and
I'm going deer [ __ ] yeah like he
didn't have the nick Bosa quads but I'm
I'm looking at him and Terrell Davis I'm
gone
similar body type yeah I compared him to
Frank Gore like a young figure he's just
so smart and instinctive as a runner
like to pick a spot and he never loses
yards he catches the ball well he's
talented if I could take to my other one
yeah please like rocky ascent from
temple like I love this he's a safety
he's a corne Horner he's big he's
physical like everyone you talked to
will be like he's just a football player
right which is like the best compliment
you can give him yeah
I like a football player I just I love
watching him play if I could only watch
two players in this draft you know for a
weekend it would be those two I like the
way they play ball
Josh Jacobs like just destroying people
yes oh yeah I'm just gonna put a
shoulder and you and put you in your
grave like that's and you're not worried
about Alabama running backs in the
history and all that stuff um I think
he's different because he was a 1 year
starter so there's not the wear and tear
coincidentally enough he is hurt right
now so I think you have to worry about I
do agree with you if you can find the
Alabama guy without the wear and tear
that's the tree I think Alabama's I
think that's changing I think so I think
they've gotten smarter about how they
take care of their players they don't
run them into the ground like they used
to which man they can't there's too much
depth like you you can't do that anymore
it's like Derrick Henry
rushing 90 times for the last two game
every you know they go for you watch how
about a film you like skip four minutes
um sometimes because the guy won't be in
on a series hmm and you're just like oh
all right the story of draft night will
be calimary yeah I have no doubt about
that
what do you think the other storylines
just kind of having done a few mocks
talking to people like what else will
define giraffe be how many defensive
players are drafted in the first round I
mean we could be looking at 23 or 24
defensive players out of the first 32
picks Wow which is just an unreal year
and now we're gonna see three or four
quarterbacks drafted a couple tight ends
couple offensive linemen but it's gonna
be two-thirds of the draft and the first
round is gonna be defense it's just a
great year for that whether it's edge
d-line you know we talked about Devon
white Devon Bush there's a lot of good
corners couple safeties yeah I think
it'll be the the guys on defense I would
say my early guys my early favorites I
think no offense he's one of my
favorites just because he's so fluid and
the way that I feel about interior pass
rushers is the way that I feel about
pass-catching tight ends I'd rather have
a great pass catching tight end than an
above-average wide receiver I just trust
them more I can use them for a million
things and the other guy that I would
say is one of my favorites I was gonna
say TJ Hawkinson I really like Anna Kiel
Harry okay oh yeah we've heard this one
yeah yeah like he was just this guy that
like dominated every time I watched a
late-night hours on a show and then I go
to the combine and all the measurables
matched up they look good why am I crazy
you're not I mean we're laughing because
our other hosts Melo loves to kill Harry
and like he's always like prove me wrong
like show me were saying we're like well
he's not fast and then he runs like a
four or five five like well [ __ ] okay no
he's good he is good I I think I have
him as my number two receiver right now
I like Nikhil Harry a lot he's gonna be
like he could be the sneaky guy like he
could be the Alshon the michael thomas
where if he if he can go to the right
team and the top of the second round
like he could be the pro bowler that
comes out of that you know second i
think that's gonna be AJ Brown when I
look at this receiver class somebody
where it's like we have just never
really been talking about him since
summer
and then you look at he was the same guy
yes so really good yeah he's great after
the catch
like he's reliable I won't act because
he played in the slot yeah okay who
cares hey runner Alex
I think that's an advantage I do too
like because I feel like I feel like the
the the increase of play action last
year they went up in the NFL and or
offensive coordinators are realizing
don't put your guy all the way out at
the hash yeah put him in the slot like
Julio Jones mainly works in the slot
right and I don't see anyone complaining
about that Cobra juju Smith shooter
Fitzgerald extended his career that way
it's just a weird thing for people to
nitpick this time of year I mean I this
is my ninth draft of bleacher report I
think it's just that time like I
remember people getting on Joey bus
because he couldn't Bend you know it's
like oh we're just arguing to argue at
this point all right I feel I have some
good notes I'm gonna have you guys come
back again I feel like you're gonna be
coming up a lot more as we get closer I
think so I think I'm gonna remember that
year where I kind of lived here I think
it's gonna be like that again
nice yeah live in a hotel no one told my
girlfriend please just walk get the
hotel two washer on DS yeah I do I mean
I we stand in an Airbnb mobile where I
had to do a scavenger hunt to find the
washer and dryer but it was like a
haunted man it was like Stan Geneva from
Red Dead yeah what yeah the house was it
was great when you guys go to a hotel do
you unpack and put your stuff in the
drawers of your bag I do i I have to
it's the first thing I do if I'm their
serial I'm there for like longer than
two days I'm in town for two nights I've
already done it Wow they don't last
night when I got in that's insane
but I'll also like take towels and I'll
put it in the drawers
I just those chairs are Kurush just
gonna say can you imagine what's been in
those drawers that's why I put towels do
I stay in hotels were there better not
be bedbugs okay all right so over the
next few weeks you're gonna have a lot
of NFL teams trying to sway you guys
trying to give you information yeah I
wish you luck the month of deception
thought he was gonna say like you know
like don't go for it I said advice he
goes good luck yeah it's right no you're
right though honestly is we joke and we
laugh about it but yeah it's it's a
wicked game
yeah but I'm excited the drafts gonna be
a lot of fun it is make sure you check
out stick to football you have a Monday
Wednesday Friday Monday was you're going
three days a week to reach a season
we're three days a week
oh yeah full time feel good I'm yeah
it's great I'm excited too like we're
gonna stretch a little bit this summer
and have fun and get back to our roots
and talking about baseball and beer and
yeah barbecue you know we we do tailgate
tours were on the road a lot with Royals
tailgate this month so really this is
the time this is the time I'll say this
too it was a it was like a bleacher
report decision I think last year where
it was like let's own the draft
year-round and you guys have kind of
owned it and I think what's cool is you
guys are more calm than I've ever seen
you like I feel like you guys have been
covering it all year to where it's not
and I know you guys always have but it
hasn't been the super grind Larry do you
feel more prepared yes yeah but I think
you can also be over-prepared where
you've like you've run so many scenarios
I was telling our producer Sean McManus
this was like let's not over prepare
because then draft night will come
around and I'll be like wait I thought
the Ravens took this guide you were that
you were that happen
we did one preparation where we would do
fake draft shows like for weeds yeah and
and then like during the draft we were
all referencing fake scenarios that we
had done we're like willing Jarvis
Landry at 17 I thought I got picked at
number nine programs yeah yeah I mean
it's
I feel better this year than ever before
because of you know doing the podcast
three times a week right as often as I
do and we have a great support staff
with stick to football weird these three
of us hosting that we can rotate you
know Connors doing two shows a week
mellows doing two shows right I'm on
three shows a week and and I think that
helps like when you get to sit down and
talk football with your best friends
yeah it's fun yeah it's always been fun
and it we haven't ever changed that's a
good thing like the show is still the
show yes it's just you know a little
more it's fun but it goes back to your
point how we're calm like I've gotten so
much better at not just taking the Excel
XI and just throwing guys around like
I'm like I know I really like it Oliver
and Quinn and Williams and like but
those are the obvious examples but even
guys in like the top of the second round
I'm like just you know
what they are yeah and now I write
everything down which I used to be
really bad at where every time I go to
change my mind I read what I wrote yeah
at the time and I go whoa oh whoa like
just relax calm down I can relax
take it easy that's all so it's you're
right you're a hundred percent right all
right get over there make sure that
you're subscribed to stick to football
we're gonna have them on again because
obviously they know what the hell
they're talking about it Nick
roll that funky beat for Connor for
Miller I am the lef koe man guys I'm
just gonna shoot my shot already this
morning I had to sit down for about a
half an hour with Charles Barkley and I
offered him to be a sports uncle that
episode is coming on Tuesday that answer
we'll find out we'll see you guys later
peace
[Music]